For the first expression, we can switch the terms in the denominator, since
addition is commutative. So we'll have x plus 7 divided by the quantity x plus
7. These expressions are identical, so we're really left with positive 1. For
the second rational expression, we know it equals negative 1. This b squared is
positive and this b squared is negative, whereas this 5 is negative and this 5
is positive. So, we definitely have opposite polynomials. We see that here, if
we just reverse the terms of the denominator and keep the signs in front of
them. We factor a negative 1 from the denominator and then the b squared minus
5s can cancel. This leaves us with negative 1. For this third one, you might
have thought it was negative 1. You might have cancelled the terms which are a
and then simplified negative 5 over positive 5. But, remember, we can't cancel
terms. We can only cancel factors. A is positive in the numerator and positive
in the denominator, so, these aren't opposite polynomials. The 5s have different
signs which mean this polynomial can't equal positive 1. It must be something
else. And for the last one, we could switch the terms in the denominator, and
then, factor a negative 1 from the numerator. The common factors of 2x minus 9
simplify to 1, leaving us with negative 1 as our result. Great work if you even
got two of those correct. These were pretty tough.